how's the residency I'm having a great
time Spain incredible no its next level
next level um how's the reaction from
the fans well let me just tell you
everyone is up singing and dancing I
mean and dancing some of the same
choreography it's like they're like true
diehard fans it's incredible it's been
really fun does it ever just trip you up
to be back at the AMAs and be like I've
made history on this stage I've
presented on this stage I've been like
this you own this you know but you come
back year after year like what a career
it's been incredible I pinch myself I'm
very humbled by it and very grateful
tell me about this fashion you look
insane and this is char Belles Oh
feathers shoo - that's okay next
question
Oh I wanted to ask you so do you watch
Dancing with the Stars at all I do of
course I think so Allie Brooke from Finn
she's killing it and Bruno last week
compared her to you oh I know it Bruno
and kerri-anne whoo I love them both and
uh that was so sweet and I actually
texted Allie and told her what a great
job she's doing yes all that matters who
wants a mirror ball Paula says you're a
good dancer she's doing great I'm really
happy for her
[Music]